don't tell us how great it is just tell
us the story
i think we all just assume that we're
all geniuses when we start
yeah you know pretty much most of us
aren't we don't want to hear this your
first pitch we don't want to hear
you know you haven't done this much we
want to hear that you practice this and
that you know exactly what to say
we want to see if you've got the goods
and that is the story like mark twain
said
don't tell us the fat lady is going to
sing bring her out let her sing
so a lot of the times people are writing
screenplays because they're writing what
they
what they've seen already because they
think that those are the movie moments
that make the film instead of realizing
that movie moment mattered because of
who those characters were and what they
were trying to get done
it means absolutely nothing in your
screenplay screenwriters are failing to
tell a story they're failing to realize
that
structure is a way to maximize
the impact of their story um and that
they
are ending up presenting a situation
instead of
telling a story one of the most
difficult things for writers
to really embrace is this is this idea
that at the very foundation of any story
is a visible goal that the hero wants to
cross at the end of the story
they'll get so caught up in the inner
journey
in the depth or dimension of the
character or in the themes they want to
deliver
or they'll just think the premise is
good so they get lost
in a thicket of events and plotting
until finally they're just coming up
with new ideas and adding idea after
idea and it becomes so complicated
and so confusing that there's no story
there
one of the illnesses of education is
they reward the mind and in storytelling
it's the heart and so you want to look
at
your vehicle as your heart
and the steering wheel as your mind
right
in story and so i said that wherever we
go
we need to be in the heart the mind
just steers us in the direction we need
to go it should help us navigate it
should help us
rearrange the the speech or the script
that is the puzzle
but it's not there because it's a
feeling
it's like music if you don't hit the
beats
then the audience won't feel it right
essentially
we're flawed people and those flaws are
going to somehow come out on screen
one of the interesting thing is our
story choice always comes from
whatever's inside of us
so i i think it's interesting when i'm
a high concept guy i come up with a
bunch of ideas and every idea i come up
with
is me and part of the job once i come up
with a high concept
is to go to trace it back and go why is
that me and once i find why it's me then
i can explore that in the script better
than just do the surface version and i
think bad high concept movies are just
the surface
you know what you know what if he's an
alien what if he's whatever and it's
like it's the surface story not
the internal story and the internal
story is what makes it human and what
makes the audience
relate to it writer forgetting about the
most important part of his story which
is the audience
his audience the reader the audience is
the most important part of the story
and when you forget it they know
the reader knows that you've forgotten
them
and then they're they're tuned out they
close the book
but i've done this myself many times
which is write
something that is personal to me that i
think i
felt something deeply about so audiences
will too
and one off no one hopes they can pull
that off
and there are some pitfalls in that
approach that often happen
one of them being that we so internalize
what we went through what we were
thinking and feeling and why it mattered
so much to us in our life
to put it actually on the page in a way
that audiences
looking at a character based on us
having experiences based on ours
for the audience to get those things
that are internal to us is harder than
it looks
and often just because we felt it deeply
doesn't mean that we can write a
character feeling that same thing deeply
and the audience will get it
sometimes they will sometimes those are
the best movies but a lot of times they
won't
and a lot of times that thing that we
went through in our personal life that
mattered so much to us
doesn't necessarily have the ingredients
of an entertaining to watch
story i have a thing i'm trying to
accomplish and that's what story is
i have a thing i am trying to accomplish
i am a character
and i need to get this thing and it will
be a more interesting story if there's
something in the way
if i am a character i'm trying to put a
suitcase on a train and i go and i put
it on the train and nothing happens
it's a very short boring story if
they're carrying a suitcase and another
person comes
and they steal the suitcase it's more of
an interesting story
and it's a more interesting story if
that person's got something important in
the suitcase if it's just a suitcase
they could say oh somebody stole it
oh well i'll go get another one not that
strong a story
every story is about a character trying
to accomplish something
and having an obstacle and what they do
what action they take in the face of the
obstacles
is your story so many writers think that
writing an outline
is figuring out the plot okay and and
and
and it's there's something very
satisfying about
coming up with a plot there's something
like oh oh i've got it but here's the
problem
is that again einstein says you can't
solve a problem
at the same level of consciousness that
created the problem every story begins
with a dramatic problem
and what happens every writers have this
experience you get really excited by
your premise
and you you start writing it and you get
halfway through and then you get stuck
and then you're trying to make these
characters interesting but you feel like
they're just
you know pieces on a chessboard that
you're trying to move around and
and so it's important to understand that
story structure
is not about plotting story structure
really is the dna
of your protagonist's transformation and
so what you really want to do
is you want to start to be curious about
your protagonist's
dilemma because when you when you really
understand the nature
of their struggle the nature of their
dilemma
it is going it becomes the source of
your story and it starts to
it just starts to pay off in silver
dollars it starts to give you
all sorts of um ideas
images scenarios that are going to
um become your plot not showing the
everyday life of the character before
they get into the story moving forward
we have to have a setup it can be very
brief or a character can be
on the move so to speak action-wise they
can have just
arrived in a town and we see them going
or they're going to a meeting or going
to meet with a hitman or whatever it
might be
but nonetheless it has to convey this is
who this character has been for some
time
and it has to create empathy we'll find
out what happened
prior to that but the big the first
big event that's going to happen to him
doesn't happen on page one
we first have to get acquainted and
identify or empathize with this
character
and that empathy must occur
immediately we have to empathize before
we start seeing what the flaws to the
character are
before we start recognizing what this
inner conflict is or what this identity
is
or what dark places they might go first
we have to just
connect with them emotionally i had a
friend of mine tell me one time that if
i ever am in a position where i have to
explain to you what my story is about
after you've read the script
then i failed if you should get it from
the script if they're not getting it
then that's a problem
you need to fix it i don't understand
why she
says this if you have to explain it then
you need to rewrite the scene
because you're not gonna what do you sit
there when the movie's going in the
theater and go
so she's doing it you know that's no
that doesn't you've got to fix it one
thing that could make
some supporting characters stronger and
screenplays in general stronger is
connecting the supporting characters to
the theme
a little bit more um i think sometimes
writers throw in you know the wacky
sidekick or you know
a supporting character who's just really
colorful and their first comedic effect
or
you know a sort of a distraction from
the a story
but really you want your screenplay
to be a collection of things that are
all having the same conversation right
so you want your screenplay to be having
one conversation all the way through
and all of those pieces should connect
to that conversation they should all
fall under that umbrella
things that jump to mind when i think
about like my particular early mistakes
i think one i was a little scared
of trusting my own point of view
i think i was relying too much on the
models of screenwriting you know looking
at
books on the hero's journey and
three-act structure and
and you know now you know some of the
more involved i was just i was obsessed
with those things i was trying to find
an answer in them
and at the end of the day like i do
think that they have some use but no for
me
i realized when i just let go of that
and just ask myself like just
core emotional and dramatic questions
first of all actually sometimes it would
result in stuff that actually had that
structure anyways inherent in it
and even when it didn't it still worked
if you want to imagine the climax of
your story
remember that we want our protagonist to
be active through the whole
story you want to have an active
protagonist
and the challenge for writers is that we
tend to be sort of passive observers
we're always watching what's going on
and so when we sometimes
put ourselves into the protagonist
situation sometimes the protagonist can
be the least interesting character in
the story
and so you want to find a way to make
them active their lead character has a
bunch of people coming at them
and doing things you know saying oh you
should do this and he goes okay and he
does it it's got if it doesn't come from
within
the character then you've got no train
you've got no choo choo
pulling the train it's not pulling the
story train what you've got is a caboose
pushing it that doesn't work
okay you need to pull it and going
somewhere
a lot of people will write pages and
pages and pages of
activity but activity is not
action right action is intentional
right people are taking intentional
steps towards a goal activity is just
anything i went to a party i sat in my
house i watched tv i did x y and z
but if that isn't attached to you
actually trying to reach a goal
then what am i watching monologues oh my
god i used to write some
obscenely long pretentious monologues
as you can probably tell i've very
opinionated about things
you know kind of philosophical about
things
and i would put way too much that into
my characters and it was annoying
first thing you have to understand about
dialogue is that
it's got to be connected to the
character's desire line
in the scene in other words if a
character
has an objective an intention in the
scene
the dialogue has to match that intention
and what i see a lot of times
especially with exposition and
information is that
a character is saying
all that information and you can tell
that it's really the
writer's objective in other words the
writer wants to
wants the audience to know this
information because they think okay the
audience needs to know this and this and
this and this so the character is going
to say this and this
and that doesn't work because scenes and
dialogue
are about a character's intention in the
scene everything a character
says is matched
to what that desire line is
so anything that doesn't belong to that
doesn't fit and you can tell
whether it's the writer wanting to know
that information wanting the audience to
not information whether it's part of the
character
on the nose dialogue could be one of the
worst
uh i like to say sometimes that talking
heads dialogue where it's just two
characters talking to each other kind of
at each other
and then q a sessions are the worst and
that's where one
character keeps asking another questions
and then they just keep answering it
so it's almost like an interview and if
that goes on for too long
it really tires out the reader and it
just gets really what we call on the
nose
seventy percent of your your exposition
does not have to go into your script
it can be all in in your cut
because all you have to do is like
is is set up a um
a visual cue with an action
and then cut to the end result of that
action
to the aftermath and just by doing that
just by putting one picture here all
right
and then putting the end result of that
picture right over here
you've downloaded your or you've
uploaded your exposition
done you know i can relate to this as a
writer it was one of my biggest
struggles
um and i never overcame it and it's part
of why i stopped writing
and i see a lot of writers with this
struggle if you are so afraid of
rejection
then it makes you or it can compel you
to be the kind of person that you think
people want you to be
and this could be true as a son or
daughter or a spouse or a writer
so you start writing in a way that you
think is what people are looking for and
you're scared of writing in a way that
could offend people
and so people who are so terrified of
rejection
can become the kind of person who
it's hard to reject but the person they
become
is not who they really are so the fear
of rejection
can lead people to reject themselves
so afraid of being rejected you reject
who you truly are